jim y la polémica que hay en torno a la
patinadora rusa cam y la válida porque
sigue la historia la polémica gira ahora
en torno a su entrenador hablamos de
teri tuberías es considerada la mejor
entrenadora de patinaje artístico del
mundo ella está al frente también de
anahí scherbakova y alexandra trusso a
compatriotas de valió a quienes ganaron
respectivamente el oro y la plata ayer
en la final individual a esta
entrenadora se la pudo ver como le
preguntaba vale va después de su
competición porque lo dejaste ir como si
le recriminara algo recordemos que la
deportista va lleva de apenas 15 años
terminó cuarta en una prueba en la que
era la gran favorita fue una charla que
continua mientras valiera esperaba en
llanto la puntuación esto fuego que
generó molestia para thomas bach a quien
es el presidente del comité olímpico
internacional quien resaltó que ya de
por sí valió ha estado sometida a una
gran presión no sólo porque buscaba el
oro sino porque su positivo por dopaje
ha sido el gran escándalo de estos
juegos escuchemos al presidente
buena after show
house luego cuando vi cómo era ella
recibida por su entorno más cercano con
tal con lo que aparentaba ser una
frialdad tremenda era escalofriante ver
esto de tve
méndez cultas
juju en lugar de darle confort en lugar
de ayudarle uno podía sentir la
atmósfera fría a la distancia gris la
atmósfera fría también recordó que desde
el coi están abordando el debate sobre
dejarán dejar a menores de edad competir
en los juegos olímpicos en las
competencias cine oral respeto de la
unión internacional de patinaje sobre
hielo explicó a la agencia afp que a
finales de este año van a votar una
propuesta para decidir si aumentan a 17
años la edad mínima para participar en
esas competencias un debate de raúl que
yo creo que ahora se abre con muy buena
razón 15 años tiene balliva sometida a
una presión enorme una presión enorme
por este esta investigación por el
dopaje y luego la entrenadora que pues
no la ayudó mucho emocionalmente hwan